[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gilles visuel les amis première sujet
premier sujet les enfants de stars au
prénom surprenant c'est plutôt drôle je
trouve ça grotesque ah bah merde et à
donner mon avis des chronos tj moteur ne
donnes pas ton avis mais c'est souvent
le meilleur samedi dernier vincent
cassel a annoncé sur instagram que sa
compagne tina kahn qui avait donné
naissance à leur premier enfant une
petite fille qu'ils ont peu exprès nommé
amazonie voilà donc elle rejoint ainsi
la longue liste des prénoms originaux on
va dire étrange donc on a fait un sujet
puis on s'est posé la question pourquoi
le font-ils est grotesque au grotesque
les rondeurs de tina laisser supposer
une arrivée imminente
vincent cassel vient d'annoncer la
naissance de la petite amazonie
oui vous avez bien entendu amazon depuis
2011 l'acteur s'engage dans la
protection de la forêt amazonienne ceci
explique cela
le marquer à pire qu'est ce que tom
cruise et katie holmes avait ému le soir
où ils ont appelé leur fille sourit sans
parler de brad pitt et angelina jolie
qui donne à leur fiche quasiment le nom
d'un médicament maddox celui là il est
bon pour dix ans de psychanalyse
monsieur et madame paltrow ont une fille
cherchez pas vous trouverez pas apple
kylie jenner a bien appelé sa fille
storni petit orage et l'acteur robin
williams accros aux jeux vidéo appelé sa
fille zelda est véridique
chez les people même le prénom des
mendois buzz et kim kardashian et non
pas les aujourd'hui six ans on frange
enceinte
on a trois et la petite dernière de 1 an
s'appelle chicago une chanson en france
en théorie on peut aussi appeler son
enfant n'importe comment
mais le juge aux affaires familiales
peut aussi demander la suppression du
prénom comme pour ce papa qui voulait
appeler son fils griezmann bape et
malheureusement pour elle la justice
n'est pas intervenue bruce willis et
demi moore ont une fille accrochez vous
bien scout larue
alors ces stars qui choisissent des
prénoms qui n'existe pas original ou
ridicule
voilà http mt people et tous les sujets
qui viennent après je te dise maintenant
impôts l'audience c'est très important
original ou ridicule c'est très très
partagés donc on va commencer par mon
avis peut-être mathieu les véhicules
pourquoi a plus que ridicule grotesque
parce que le prénom c'est un marqueur
social alors c'est si vous appelez
justin c'est bien si vous vous appelez
un nom de cendrillon par exemple c'est
moins bien on voit hélas on a
l'impression que ces dames des gens qui
à tout prix ne veulent pas donner le
prénom susceptibles d'être donné par les
enfants de leurs employés de maison
leurs voisins ou leurs fans
il ya vraiment regarder on va faire
super original parce qu on est différent
c'est ridicule il ya quand même
l'exemple du couturier courage qui avait
appelé sa fille clafoutis elle a quand
même saisi la justice pour se rappeler
marie par semaine ça traumatise tout le
monde mais moi je vous donne un exemple
ont même sac ma femme ma femme un prénom
improbable c'est pas mal s'appelle
verlaine alors c'est joli et vous amis
génial en france ça n'existe pas vers
l'aide comme prénom
non mais ça va se passer je lis quand
même est-ce que vous savez quelque à une
fouille à unir tous préparent contre
exemple puisque donc ta femme n'est pas
pardon ta femme n'est pas connue elle
est la femme de mutuelles therman mais
ça n'est pas une singularité des comment
dire des people d'avoir d'abord du fait
une singularité souvent de gens qui
vient des gens vous ai donné la parole
non mais je la prends parce que quand
vous regardez ça va pas grand temps
voilà de voir tous ces thèmes qu'il ya
une étude qui est montré qu'ils bonnes
années 90 les prénoms américains avec
toutes les séries beverly ce qui
arrivait kevin aujourd'hui kevin réduit
de 30% les chances d'avoir un emploi sur
un cv parce que dès qu'on va le prénom
kevin 0 qu'est kevin à fond se dit voilà
il est débile ou hulu voilà alors ça
peut en plus un bon mais au tour de
kévin bon voilà alors sert madame
catherine catherine mills et moi dans
l'oreillette 1 pour les mêmes raisons
que tu as marqueur social
eva guillaume marion a raison aussi
c'est pas que l'apanage des stars de
données présent ridicule moi j'allais
ali je me suis procuré la liste des
prénoms qui ont aussi d'être donnés en
france qui ont été refusées tenez vous
un agent qu'on voulait et non pas des
stars comme la peur enfants bob l'eponge
excellent anomalie * nos mini cooper
dans quel élan qui aime bien les bananes
août et la recette est refusé lucifer
clafoutis fraises spirou accès direct
aux qui les prenons du beau être plus en
point à 40 proposait en effet des
batailles
comment s'est décidée par qui s'est
alors renversé le
l'officier d'état civil qui quand il
sent que le prénom conduire l'enfant
transmet le dossier au procureur d'albi
méritée pour les stars comme ce côté
monfils forcément ma fille je suis star
n'aura pas le prénom des aux séquelles
mais lui sinon alors pour les beckham
c'est là où vous avez couché
donc oui à brooklyn noir des bruits mais
c'est comme si j'avais mon fils tu tiens
le coup c'est drôle
[Applaudissements]
voilà peu dibert le fils de jamie oliver
venus bon voilà bon kallel le fils de
nicolas skate tim elvis pas ils ont tous
des prénoms sa ligne et à lourdes est où
ça va c'est quand même gros test non des
enfants est ce que quelqu'un que les
enfants de brad pitt le nom de madoff
s'est lui dénoncé en france il ya des
gens campent et leur fisc littorine
l'eau avait raconté dit quoi en france
il ya des gens qui ont aimé leur fille
en 2014 cris taurine nino ricci taurine
c'est pas facile je vous dirai pas
clitoridienne ou merde mais re div
[Applaudissements]
ça a été acceptée c'est les prénoms qui
sont étrangers à accepter al capone al
bashir al pacino et en un seul mot
justin ça serait pour ou que vous cadrez
mais des gis justin avec un dé d'abord
de la fin bien des noms ridicules et qui
ont été acceptées oui ce n'était que 5e
13 donnant par rapport à ce que tu
disais tout à l'heure vous n'êtes pas
des graves